L FORMERSIDENT I
HE WAS GEARINGTHCL
USED TO B
CONFEEN HELD
THOLD CLIN
ENERGIZED TH IT'N.
PROGRAM.YOTHE MI
RTION
FEW VERYCOTHE HISTORN OI
HEGSNOTE THE
REIC CL
BECAUSE THEY N TG DAYLIGHT
THEORY S WERS.THN ER RAC
SMALLPOX.
AMERICAT S .TISE PES JUSTO HE S
MORELEY RANT, PUE AND EOE THE EE
HA TRYING  YI ON.
ALO  THEM IMAIR PUT,I RAND HE
AZAN OPE
LISTIN
BUIFU WEREN, THEY WOULD NOT LIS.
>> THAT'GHANPPTHINGS. WE SUDE UL
YOU KNOWD ENL
10 YEARS OLD,
I DON'T WANT TO DOTO
INTERFERE WIRIT CT ESLI AREE TH
OFSEN INDRIVE-BY SHOOTINGS?
ULOU LIKE TOTHAT?
ALK ABOUT THE NRA. PEOPLE. I DI.
E MATHEM
BUEED LIFROM ONE SIDE ORVE A
IT IS HARDANIT'S MUC
DI.
N  HARTHEN
KEEP ATLL
WORD.SED ON PEOPLE. PLATFORM TO
LIVES.
OTR E HE CULTURER IS ALWAYS
O THE D THIS
IS WHAT THE PRES GUARDBE
THE DRAMA OF TWO PEOPLMORE
BUILD A K WHAIWHHYD THING  YOUAC
CAAIG  M
IT AALT CANCEL
CULTURE, ABOUTRITICAL RACE ITYO.
RON DeSANTISLS ABOUT THAT.
WILL IWORKG VENEZUELANS WHOMLEE
DISASTBEY
, A ANCONOMI
VINEYARD IS
THBOL OF THE ELITE
TID FOR PEOPLE W ON
TH,  AE
FIRST PLACE THAT WELCOMED BLACP
H TO COME N EQ ALY
EAREFLECTIONST